il ya quelques jours je vous parlais du
rock fun 2 josé un homme boxing et je
vous montre un peu les différents
accessoires qu'on pouvait avoir avec
aujourd'hui je suis allé plus loin j'ai
joué avec le rock fun 2 celle des trucs
vraiment cool et je trouve que dans
l'univers du smartphone gaming c'est
quelque chose qui est vraiment très
bluffant extrêmement bien maîtrisée de
la part d'asus faut pas oublier que rock
français asus et c'est vraiment vraiment
bien alors leurs fans en lui-même c'est
une vraie bête de compet c'est vraiment
un truc de fou ce qu'ils lui ont encore
plus dingue si particulier ce sont ces
accessoires on va se faire un tour
complet de ce smartphone
on va regarder les accessoires et vous
allez voir le truc est franchement si
vous êtes gamer si vous voulez utiliser
un smartphone de gaming franchement
drôle fun ii et officines par contre
tous a un certain coût
[Musique]
non
on sait que quand on parle d'un
smartphone de rim quand on veut acheter
un smartphone de gaming c'est bien
évidemment tout d'abord pour pouvoir
jouer ça paraît assez logique au vu de
la performance on veut un bel écran en
jeu le yacht dingue on veut pas se
prendre la tête on de se connecter vite
on a un truc qui marche très bien et
très facilement en gros ça résume
parfaitement bien ce smartphone mais on
veut pas que ça parce que on a pas que
l'usagé du jeu on va aussi l'utiliser
pour passer des coups de fil
on va utiliser pour envoyer des messages
l'utiliser pour faire des photos en gros
il ya plein d'usagé regarder des séries
des films et compagnie il nous faut ce
smartphone qui soit vraiment excellent
dans son domaine de prédilection qu'est
le gaming là dessus mais il faut aussi
un smartphone qui soit très bon dans le
reste parce que si vous avez une superbe
est pour le gaming à côté le reste un
peu bullshits à craindre et alan
rassurez-vous le rock faune deux à plein
de belles qualités il a un poids qui est
un peu plus faiblard si je vous le dirai
que d'informer sur le reste je trouve
vraiment bien
si vous êtes un gamer ou games et que
vous aimez les smartphones avec un look
racé franchement avec le rock 22 vous
allez très heureux et très heureuse par
contre smartphones qui est un petit peu
lourd 240 grammes et sera plus lourd que
ce qu'on peut retrouver sur le marché
à côté de ça vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut en terme de techno et complet pour
le refroidissement tout ça forcément va
rajouter du point mais sinon le
smartphone en lui-même est vraiment bien
petit éclairage arrière qui va venir
changer en fonction de vos paramétrages
mais un dépôt extrêmement pendant son
smartphone c'est son écran vous avez un
écran amoled hdr 6,59 pouces avec une
résolution full hd plus de 1340 par 1080
pixels un écran corning gorilla glass si
ce ratio 19 points 5/9 et surtout avec
un taux de rafraîchissement complètement
dingue de 120 hertz qui va être vraiment
fluide lorsque vous en avez besoin vous
un temps de réponse de une milliseconde
entre un truc qui est vraiment bien des
gens tout ce qui fait la force
lorsque vous allez jouer lorsque vous
êtes vraiment nom du gaming ceop vous
venez là vous rentrez dans le mode
spécial gaming de ce smartphone
et là vous allez avoir tous vos jeux et
vous avez notamment le profil de jeu ça
c'est un truc qui vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien voulu pouvoir venir tout
régler vous allez pouvoir régler le
toucher et surtout le taux de
rafraîchissement comme vous le souhaitez
soit comme le système soit vraiment peut
venir le régler et ça je pars je 60
hertz 90 hier ou carrément 120 hertz
s'étouffer zimmer 120 hertz à la
consommer davantage de batterie vous
pouvez venir ensuite régler vos
performances vous les performances
maximales vous voulez pousser le cpu
à fond pouvait faire vous pouvez venir
régler les choses comme vous le
souhaitez votre consommation le mode de
température nettoyaient les mois
compagnie pareil pour l'audio pour les
appels et pour le réseau j'en finis avec
ce mode tant que je suis dessus qui est
vraiment vraiment intéressant vous avez
aussi votre console vous allez pouvoir
avoir toutes les informations vous
activez aussi le modique sous palm os x
alors le modique c'est en gros le mode
ultra performant ce qui va pousser la
machine à fond
vous allez consommer davantage de
batterie mais par contre à la barre tout
complètement incroyable une machine
vraiment sûr booster avait fait savoir
qu'en performance vous avez un
snapdragon 855 plus qu' aujourd'hui ce
qui a de plus puissant sur le marché ce
qui se fait de mieux
tous à coupler à 12 giga de ram 512 giga
de stockage on a un truc est purement et
simplement hallucinant une machine qui
est extrêmement rapide très racée et je
vous dis nous veillons plus le booster
avec le mode x là vous avez une vraie
fusée dans la main tous les jours on
tournait parfaitement bien extrêmement
rapidement donc en termes de
performances pour du jeu prévenir tout
régler alors bien évidemment plus vous
allez boosté à fond et plus votre
autonomie risque de diminuer rapidement
mais soyez rassurés vous avez une très
grosse batterie de 6000 milliampères
heures c'est un truc de fou
ça rajoute forcément un petit peu de
poids mais ça marche vraiment bien
l'autonomie pour moi elle est vraiment
tout simplement énorme alors une fois de
plus l'autonomie c'est toujours un petit
peu délicat parce que ça dépend toujours
vous de votre utilisation
mais les deux jours là dessus vous les
avez si par contre vous poussez pensant
variance vous pousser toutes les
performances à fond et vous jouer
énormément les deux jours vous aurez pas
à côté de ça et point extrêmement
positif
vous avez un chargeur rapide de 30 watts
là vous rechargez le smartphone assez
rapidement et ça c'est vraiment bien
et puis je vous le montre l autre jour
si vous craignez pour la chauffe vous
avez aussi un accessoire presque
incontournable autres cas très
intéressant qui est fourni avec son
petit ventilateur externe c'est l'aéro
active couleurs 2 vous permettra de
baisser la température de 5 degrés de
votre smartphone aucune fois qu'il est
très très chaud et bien ça peut vraiment
venir être couleur grande section guinea
vous venez enlevé là là vous avez une
connectique spéciale je vous montrais
aussi lors de leurs boxes l'autre jour
on vient mettre son ventilateur là qui
se connecte directement hop tac tac tac
donc là vous avez votre petit logo
republic of gamers la lumière retrouvé
derrière parce que forcément l'autre est
caché le petit ventilateur il n'est pas
extrêmement bruyant ça va ça fonctionne
plutôt bien et surtout ce qui est bien
voyez c'est que en termes de prise en
main et bien vous est quand même
vachement cool avec votre smartphone de
chaque côté
il faut savoir déjà nativement et
arrière vous attend refroidissement
interne à chambre à vapeur
fait déjà taclé lorsque vous poussez les
performances à fond le fait d'avoir un
petit ventilateur en complément vous
gagnez en température 5 degrés donc
s'associent maintenant il ya un point
qui est aussi extrêmement important
lorsque vous jouez un jeu vous regarder
du contenu multimédia
c'est la partie expérience sonore est là
dessus une fois de plus vous avez un
truc est vraiment intéressant c'est le
fait d'avoir les deux haut parleurs en
façade alors ses deux haut parleurs en
façade apporte quelque chose qui est
bien c'est effectivement de l'immersion
parce que le son vous arrive d'un côté
et de l'autre de la même manière donc
vous n'avez pas un côté qui va être un
petit peu plus faible a reconnu comme
sur un smartphone un peu classique avec
des haut-parleurs stéréo parce que
souvent on va voir un premier haut
parleurs qui va envoyer du som l'autre
sur le côté pas la même directivité du
sont pas la même puissance peuvent être
performants sont pas les hauts parleurs
là par contre les deux sont exactement
les mêmes vous avez la même direction
est et du sol ou quelque chose qui est
assez intéressant est beaucoup plus
immersif c'est un peu ce qu'on retrouve
également sur le pixel 3 mpixels 3xl
notamment de google
donc c'est pas la même chose on va
chercher la même chose avec ces produits
mais le fait d'avoir cédé aux parlera au
passage trouve ça bien donc ça vient
renforcer le côté immersif parce que
vous jouez par contre un point négatif
et vous avez une bande noire à droite et
à gauche ou alors on est et on va tout
dépend comment voter vos smartphones si
vous aimez les design bord à bord là
pour que vous n'allez pas être servi
mais par contre pour l'expérience sonore
pure et simple ça crache il ya vachement
fond d'un côté de l'autre
mais lorsque vous allez jouer ça devient
en plus rajouté en sensation d'immersion
c'est très bien lorsque vous jouez un
jeu comme ça vous l'utilisez à la main
comme pour n'importe quel smartphone
mais le truc on a des chances de se son
mais le tout parce que ça craque
vraiment très fort mais truc qui est
vachement mais surtout c'est d'utiliser
tous les accessoires que vous avez
derrière comme je le disais côté
accessoires ce truc un petit peu on what
the fuck que vous avez avec ce
smartphone parce que vous avez une
pléiade d'accessoires vous avez plein
plein plein plein de trucs et c'est
vraiment vraiment cool mais ce que je
préfère que je trouve à sumatra sont qui
arrivait cette année c'est le rogue
kunai bien de pâtes qui vient remplacer
le game vice que vous avez l'année
dernière ne gagne pas que c'était
marrant mais il n'était pas parfait je
veux pas dire que c'est parti ce coup ci
mais ça va dans le bon sens vous avez
votre smartphone qui est comme ça
vous voulez branché l'utiliser comme une
manette un peu en rond comme une
nintendo smith alors vous avez cette
espèce de coke que vous ne leur présente
un peu peur parce que je trouve ça un
peu fragile en fait c'est très léger
alors c'est bien ce que ça rajoute pas
de poids on vient juste en gros le
connecter il faut le manipuler avec
précaution
vous avez une petite connectique ici
vous venez le brancher dans la prise
sb c'est que vous avez là donc ça vient
ça s'emboîte a fait que vraiment
doucement parce que je ne doute pas que
ce soit résistant mais je sois pas très
épais ensuite on vient on clique ici qui
caoutchouc conway de chaque côté et là
vous venez branchez vos contrôleurs
votre manette le truc est extrêmement
simple et au final votre smartphone va
ressembler à une nintendo switch vous
avez donc un smartphone console que vous
utilisez comme ça ça vous évite d'avoir
les doigts sur l'écran
là vous avez des boutons dédiés vous les
sentez soudoie vous vantez vous
expliquer ce qu'est qu'une console mais
en gros ça d'être à 100 mais vraiment
votre rock band 2 ans console donc la
voyez j'ai une toute autre expérience de
jeu je peux venir déraper j'utilise
directement mais bouton pour faire
toutes les actions ici je dérape je fais
des pirouettes je peux lancer mais turbo
directement la up je change ma direction
je fais ce que je veux comme je veux et
ça je trouve que c'est vachement cool
ans l'âge utilise sera soit 9
mais je peux aussi bien l'utiliser par
exemple sur pozzi pour jouer un peu
obligé de la même manière ça marche
vachement bien le seul truc par contre
c'est qu'il faut que vous mmes à pied
les touches c'est à dire que vous êtes
obligés de les paramétrer par défaut ça
va pas les reconnaître pour venir les
maps et vous montez sur le côté ici dont
votre game genie vous avez tous vos
paramètres vous mettez dans le mappage
des touches bien vous venez tout
paramétrer une fois que c'est fait vous
appuyer là il voyait en règle générale
vous venez vous glisser là et là vous
avez tous vos paramètres là je suis en
30 images par seconde je vois la
température joue à la fréquence du
processeur
j'ai le mode x qui est activé et on se
voyait pas mal de petits paramétrage
donc cet accessoire pour l'utiliser
directement comme ça mais vous avez
aussi cette petite partie là alors en
gros que vous expliquer le truc ça c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que lorsque
vous jouez en utilisant un autre
accessoire que vous avez vous pouvez
acheter en plus
et bien vous allez pouvoir poser votre
smartphone sur un petit dock et sur un
dock un peu plus compliqué pour
l'utiliser et vous allez pouvoir
l'utiliser effectivement grâce à cette
manette et là vous allez pouvoir
commander votre jeu à distance via un
accessoire que j'aime beaucoup c'est
celui-là c'est le twin view doc vous
venez l'ouvrir vous enlevez une fois de
plus votre petit capuchon de sécurité
qui se trouve son votre smartphone vous
venez insérez votre robe phone
directement à l'intérieur vous levez
vous clipser vous verrouillez derrière
pour pas que ça bougeait pas que ça
tombe et là vous allez pouvoir utiliser
votre rock food comme une console qui
sait toutes vos applications qui sont
installés vous avez si un bouton de
volume pour venir des ses leçons et
montent elles sont un bouton pour venir
l'allument
est allumée est carrément tout éteindre
le smartphone est une idée de qui il
faut savoir qu'au dessus vous avez cas
rien d'un écran amoled d'un écran amoled
2 6 pouces fhd vous avez quatre haut
parleurs à l'avant vous avez donc deux
haut parleurs là vous avez donc deux
haut parleurs aura donc deux fois plus
de son vous avez en plus une batterie de
6000 milan perd heures à l'intérieur
c'est le truc le plus tôt bien se tient
bien en main
donc ça c'est vachement cool notamment
sera salle parce que voyez en haut j'ai
mon écran pour jouer en bas j'ai la
course là j'ai mon tour beaumont booster
là je vais pouvoir venir déraper donc je
l'utilisé vraiment pour pouvoir
commander comme une deuxième manette je
choisis ma direction
à droite ou à gauche en balayant l'écran
du bas enfin un petit coup de boost je
dérape
je change de direction directement sur
ça vachement bien c'est vraiment sympa
parce que vous permet de rajouter pas
mal de choses à l'expérience du jeu cet
accessoire est cool ça dépend des jeux
auxquels vous aviez joué mais je trouve
vachement bien vous pouvez aussi venir
leurs charges et en usb c'est vous êtes
vraiment flatteur pour le refroidir moi
je trouve intéressant ça rajoute une
autre expérience aux jeux et c'est
vraiment bien et ça marche parfaitement
bien une fois de plus avec sur olten de
je voulais toujours et je le répèterai
pas assez il faut protéger vos
smartphones vous avez si une coque asus
republic of gamers qui est là on est
vraiment dans la vienne du smartphone
vraiment extrêmement typé light armor
caisse a été détectée ça vous fait donc
une coque qui changent de couleur qui
est vachement bien voilà qui détecte et
qui est reconnu pour que là j'ai branché
cette petite bête là qui s'appelle le
'mobile' des stops doc
c'est donc un doc sur lequel vous allez
brancher des périphériques qui vous
allez pouvoir retrouver ensuite ici
alors là par exemple je l' ai branché en
hdmi sur mon écran sont à ma télé mais
vous pouvez brancher plein d'autres
choses parce que vous avez plein de porc
dessus et c'est vraiment ça tout
l'intérêt de ce produit là vous allez
pouvoir notamment rajouter une carte sd
brancher un disque dur en externe
clavier souris un moniteur ici je vous
ai mis une télé vous pouvez mettre un
moniteur met un écran mais ce que vous
voulez utiliser votre rock food comme un
ordinateur pour des sessions gaming
clavier souris écran
c'est complètement possible alors comme
suit pas gamer il ya des choses que je
pourrais pas vous montrer notamment le
fait de jouer clavier souris écran j'ai
pas mais vous pouvez le faire ça c'est
pratique
à voir la commencer vous en avez lusage
d'ailleurs dit le mont amba en
commentaire autre accessoire qui est
vachement bien c'est sartre que jeunes
branchés c'est le wheeling displayed hoc
en gros c'est un dock qui l'avenir
pouvoir connecter votre smartphone
directement à votre pied alors là je les
brochets derrière en hdmi
j'ai une prise pour le branché en hdmi
c'est aussi ça c'est l'alimentation
bouton on off l'idée c'est que j'ai eu
mon roc faune de la tuque pouvoir tout
recopier en direct faire des jeux alors
typiquement ici pour venir jouer à
publie je vais avoir voyez mon écran qui
est directement posée ici une recopier
donc là lorsque vous jouez avec des amis
que voulait faire une soirée que vous
voulez vous la péter lire garde comme je
joue bien at elle je t'aime je t'aime je
vous voulez faire tourner la balle est
entre vous vous pouvez le faire ça c'est
plutôt bien alors sur ppj ça marche
vachement bien par contre à sfax neuf ça
marche pas sur asphalte 9g le jeu
effectivement qui est là sur ma manette
mais ça leur copie pas sur l'écran alors
si vous connaissez d'astuces vous pouvez
me l'a donnée parce que moi je suis
demandeur je n'ai pas réussi à côté de
ça je trouve que c'est vraiment hyper
pratique alors vous ayez la manette
comme ça ou pas moi je la lis parce que
pour jouer c'est quand même vachement
mieux mais si vous n'avez pas enfin ma
manette on peut l'utiliser en format
smartphone classique sarko pis c'est
pratique ça c'est vachement sympa j'ai
un autre point qui est important et pas
des moindres c'est la partie photo vous
avez donc trois capteurs trois caméras
fort ce smartphone vous avez une
première caméra de 48 mégapixels c'est
la sony mx 5 186 vous en ai déjà parlé
une deuxième caméra 13 mégapixels c'est
un ultra grand-angle de 125 degrés puis
vous avez une caméra de saïfi qui se
cachent juste là de 24 mégapixels
c'est peut-être là où le bât blesse ou
le smartphone n'est pas hyper hyper
optimisé caméra de celle fille bon le
rendu est correcte sans être
complètement fou ça fait le taff la
caméra principale fait le job
j'ai connu beaucoup mieux avec des
sonics 586 ça fait le taf il vous faut
de la lumière ça fera le job mais ce
n'est pas complètement faux
jutras grand-angle pas mieux il fait le
boulot on arrive quand même avoir un
rendu qui est qualitatif mais bon vous
voyez je suis pas hyper hyper emballé
jusqu'en 1 à l'intérieur de ce
smartphone on pourra voir beaucoup mieux
en terme de rendu photo là capteur
principal la ultra grand-angle c'est
bien mais vu les performances de la
machine et vu ce qu'on en captant
derrière on pourrait aller beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin carrosserie
mégapixels là c'est déjà un petit peu
mieux mais s'en est complètement leur
ultra grand-angle
bon alors clairement ça fait le taf on
va pas dire que c'est pas bien que la
qualité n'est pas bonne mais vu ce qu'on
en termes de performances pures m'en
fiche technique à l'intérieur c'est un
dragon 855 +12 ian brown devrait quand
même une sony mx 5 186 tout ça d'un
point de vue purement technique marche
bien mais je pense que d'un point de vue
logiciel ça pourrait être encore mieux
exploiter bon c'est un point
probablement à perfectionner qui
fonctionne pas mal
à côté de ça vous n'allez pas acheter ce
smartphone pour aller chercher à faire
des photos de dengue à devenir l'insta g
ou instagram
pour une expérience de gaming par contre
c'est vraiment bien fait à noter qu'il
est aussi un bon boulot qu'ils étaient
faits en terme de connexion parce que
vous avez plusieurs antennes wi fi à
l'intérieur pour toujours mieux pouvoir
vous connecter
et surtout ne jamais être coupée lorsque
vous jouerez sap c'est vraiment
important
voilà pour ce rock fun2 je sais pas
comment vous le trouver est ce que vous
le trouver intéressant moi
personnellement je trouve vraiment cool
très bien réussi de la part d'asus ont
pas plus un produit qui est très bien
très haut de gamme qui est vraiment cool
la partie photo on est un peu en dessous
mais ce n'est pas extrêmement grave
parce que c'est pas ce qu'on va
rechercher en priorité que ce soit en me
rassura vous offrez quand même de bonnes
photos de bons souvenirs ça marche alors
je donne tout au terme de tarifs parce
que c'est là un petit pot bât blesse
le produit bien mais qui dit produit
bien une bonne qualité du produit
forcément cher après par un poste clé
dans le ventre et par rapport à ce qui
existe à la concurrence s'est pas
complètement dingue le asus rog teun de
groot 899 99 centimes ce qui coûte 900
euros c'est un certain prix bien
évidemment mais quand vous voyez tout ce
qui la met par ailleurs tout ce qui peut
faire c'est pas énorme mais que je vous
conseille mme ocana elle se produit
c'est d'avoir peut-être un ou deux
accessoires en fonction bien évidemment
de vos besoins
alors dans la partie accessoires on va
commencer par lui le mobile destock doc
écoute 199,99 et coûte 200 euros c'est à
dire que si vous achetez votre iphone
plus fin vous êtes déjà à 1100 euros
alors n'oubliez pas qu'il faut rajouter
en plus le prix moniteur clavier/souris
manque vous les ayez déjà mais c'est
plutôt sympa alors lui j'ai pas le prix
par contre du rogue kunai gamepad je
n'ai pas trouvé le prix sur le site de
asus donc voilà je vais pas vous donner
de l'info là dessus mais par contre que
ce soit est vachement bien mais pour moi
c'est je dirais un des premiers
accessoires achetés si on veut tout
simplement parce que ça va permettre
d'utiliser votre smartphone comme une
manette ça vous libère de l'écran c'est
plus intuitif parce que vous savez tout
de suite où positionner vaudois entre
accessoires qui est cool c'est lui la
wigig display doc accessoires l' écoute
un petit peu chiant à coup deux 169.99
donc il faut vraiment en avoir l'utilité
autres accessoires qui y praille
traîtera cool c'est le twin view doc par
contre que quand même 329 euros 99 il
est extrêmement cher donc si vous voulez
acheter votre smartphone et win the doc
voyez tout remonte à un petit peu en
plus par contre l'expérience derrière
elle est vraiment vraiment cool tendance
et une coque de protection que vous
montrez qui est vachement plus du coûte
40 euros puis elle
cette banane dont je vous en parle très
rapidement c'est si on veut avoir un
petit sac banane asus moi je ne suis pas
très fan des petit sac banane stralka
londonien vous le match et comme vous
voulez je suis pas extrêmement fans mais
bon pourquoi pas si vous voulez avoir la
complète vous pouvez le faire donc voyez
tous ces accessoires mais boutabout
coûte forcément un certain prix
j'imagine qu'on va pas tous les acheter
à moins de péter la tirelire très belle
réussite de la part de asus très beau
smartphone très belle écosystèmes après
avoir si effectivement ils seront
confirmés ce qu'ils ont déjà fait avec
le asus rog phone qui était déjà un
excellent smartphone à voir si le asus
rog phone deux rencontres autant le
succès mais en tout cas en termes de
performances en termes d'autonomie en
termes de qualité d'écran d'odieux
d'expérience de gaming c'est vraiment
une bête de compet c'est un excellent
smartphone si vous voulez quelque chose
qui est vraiment bien dans le gaming
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
performant en endurance
vous allez pouvoir regarder je pense
minimum 2 ans en restant toujours un
jour dans le catalogue est bien celui là
franchement vous n'allez pas être déçu à
vous parce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire moi je trouve cool
il n'est pas du tout destiné à tout le
monde ce smartphone il est vraiment
destiné à un public très nicher on sait
qu'on est de plus en plus nombreux à
jouer mais a joué d'accord mais à aller
sur des smartphones de gaming
ça reste quand même un peu plus ni chez
comme public comme clients des lignes
dites moi si ça vous intéresse et
d'ailleurs vous êtes dans la cible est
ce que vous pourriez être tenté ce que
vous avez le smartphone de game ou d'une
marque concurrente par quelques mois en
bas en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain voilà où des gros
bisous ciao